c'est vraiment des agressions répétées
on vit socom sûr en tant que victime on
voit nos nos agresseurs
nous attaquer finalement dans des
procédures judiciaires quand fini jean
simard affirme avoir subi des abus
physiques et sexuels durant l'enfance il
résidait à l'orphelinat du mont
d'youville opéré par les soeurs de la
charité
depuis 2020 ils se battent pour obtenir
justice dans le cadre d'un recours
collectif contre la congrégation
bien son particulier nous savons sur
section à alès comme un teaser contrat
mais lloris
personnes abonnées à
actionner une
loutre est réversible il espère que les
excuses prononcées jeudi par le taq
françois québec feront bouger les choses
ce qui avait demandé des actions fortes
de la part des congrégations religieuses
laurent longtemps vraiment processus de
reconsidérer conciliation parce qu'il ya
de l'action qui se passe moi je croyais
plus ainsi à ses excuses sébastien
richard est partagé pour lui ce n'est
pas suffisant pour nous les du tueur
allochtone là il faut pas avoir une
directive extrêmement clair ou
communautés religieuses et au diocèse
pour que les rues au collectif plus
rêver pierre bolduc aurait subi des
sévices au sein d'une autre
congrégations religieuses il croit que
le pape aurait dû aller plus loin en
reconnaissant un règlement systémique de
l'église dans les agressions les
agresseurs ont le soleil mais dans mon
dos et les personnes qui le déplacer ses
patrons il est en cours à une pile
déplaçait dans juno par white
c'est un genre que les vrais coupables
dans de nombreux dossiers plusieurs
victimes alléguées sont décédés avant la
conclusion des procédures judiciaires
24 recours collectifs sont en cours deux
mille cinq cents victimes alléguées
attendent c'est pour cela que les
plaignants souhaitent que les
communautés religieuses collaborent pour
accélérer les démarches
c'est quelque chose qui peut porter
fruit si c'est entendu par les
congrégations religieuses jean simard ne
perd pas espoir alors que le pape
rentrer au vatican c'est peut-être une
nouvelle ère qui s'amorce pour les
victimes canadiennes ici flavie
sauvageau radio canada québec